nadège bonsoir alors quels sont les
derniers éléments dont vous disposez sur
place après ces attentats
bah écoutez olivier le deuil et le
recueillement laisse place à la
polémique ici en autriche à les services
secrets du pays aurait été mise au
courant que l'assaillant de 20 ans
responsable de la mort de quatre
personnes auraient cherché à se procurer
des munitions aux recherches et à
s'armer l information émane du ministre
autrichien de l'intérieur en personne
blanche au cours des dernières heures
des informations sont apparus montrant
que quelques temps avant l' attaque
terroriste
les services secrets slovaque avait
informé les services du renseignement
autrichien au sujet de l'assaillant il
avait indiqué qu'il voulait se procurer
des munitions dans ce qui a suivi
il y a évidemment eu des problèmes dans
la communication est un chiffre
également les services secrets
autrichien était donc au courant qu'un
ancien détenu condamné en 2019 pour
avoir voulu faire le djihad en syrie
cherchait à s'armer sans avoir été
stoppé par qui que ce soit pour tenter
de justifier ce qui s'apparente à un
raté des services de secret des service
des renseignements le ministre
autrichien de l'intérieur a accusé son
prédécesseur est d'extrême droite
d'avoir agi est sérieusement dans le
cadre de ses fonctions
contre le sicile contre les services de
renseignements
je dois faire attention à trouver les
bons mots qui conviennent à un ministre
il va de soi que l'ancien ministre
herbert qui cueille qui est responsable
de la destruction du service de
renseignement en autres
qui doit maintenant être reconstruit et
celui qui aujourd'hui crient le plus
fort des querelles politiciennes qui
n'intéresse pas vraiment les viennois
dans ce contexte de tragédie nationale
eux préfèrent elles se recueillir et
rendre hommage aux victimes
je pense qu'il est bien du moins de ce
que j'ai pu voir aux informations que la
slovaquie a essayé de communiquer à ce
sujet avant les attaques
je n'en suis pas sûr mais il aurait
peut-être pu faire quelque chose en
amont pour éviter ce qui s'est passé
mais il est toujours facile d'en parler
après les faits
j'ai envie de vous dire que si quelqu'un
a envie de se procurer des armes il peut
s'en procurer n'importe où ce n'est de
la faute de personne les gens disent que
c'est la faute de notre gouvernement
c'est la faute à tout le monde mais ce
n'est la faute de personne
et si ce genre de personne vous se
procurer des armes il en aura peu
importe l'endroit
c'est peut-être une faille mais je pense
qu'il est trop tôt pour en parler nous
ne connaissons pas encore l'histoire
dans son intégralité
originaire de macédoine du nord
l'assaillant de 20 ans a été tué lors de
cette attaque terroriste après avoir lui
même assassiné quatre personnes et en
ont blessé une vingtaine d'autres lui
qui a donc bénéficié d'une libération
anticipée en 2019 et qui a réussi à
tromper le programme de déradicalisation
et les personnes qui étaient assurés de
son suivi à l'heure avant de prendre de
court incontestablement les services de
renseignement et donc de passer à l'acte
à sebastian course a appelé l'union
européenne à se pencher sérieusement sur
la menace islamiste
on apprend ce soir qu emmanuel macron
devrait se devrait arriver ici jusqu'ici
à vienne lundi prochain justement pour
s'entretenir avec le chancelier
autrichien pour parler de la lutte
contre le terrorisme